andy barkley was born on november 9
1982. we know this because his sixth
birthday ends up being the same day as
charles lee ray's death day which we see
here and here there's also one document
suggesting that he was born on january
4th 1983 however this isn't an official
file this is just the toy company's file
on it so it may be less likely to be
accurate later on you'll see why it
probably isn't accurate but we'll get
back to that as a kid andy's favorite
food is chocolate and he also likes eggs
at night his mom would sing him to sleep
andy's father is not around anymore the
original script of child's play mentions
that he had died in a car accident
however i won't consider that canon as
it's not in the movie we first meet andy
on his sixth birthday in 1988. he woke
up early to watch tv and disastrously
tried to make breakfast for his mother
he sees the commercial for the good guy
doll on tv and is extremely impressed
and wants one for himself he's at that
age where he's so impressionable that he
can easily be swayed into wanting
something or believing something had he
been a little bit older maybe what
happened next could have been entirely
avoided he wakes up his mom and asks if
he can open presents in addition to some
new clothes he gets a good guy's branded
tool chest but understandably he wants a
good guy to go with it that evening his
wish would come true when his mom
surprised him with one
hi i'm chucky and i'm your friend to the
end heidi ho
this would be one of those examples of
be careful what you wish for as this
birthday present would completely [ __ ]
up the rest of andy's life to learn how
andy grew up to adapt to childhood
trauma stick around to the end of this
video this video is sponsored by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
welcome to things you missed i just
realized this is actually horror history
i said the wrong thing andy barkley is
actually kind of an outlier when it
comes to slasher movie protagonist in
that he's managed to stay alive the
entire time he's even mostly been
covered by the same actor alex vincent
the only exception is in child's play 3
where they wanted to tell the story of
an older andy without waiting for alex
vincent to get older so a kid by the
name of justin whalen filled in on that
one at this point there's also a third
actor to play andy which would be
gabriel bateman in the child's play
remake but that's an entirely different
character so that'll maybe be its own
episode of horror history i said the
right thing that time to understand this
andy let's take it back to the moments
that changed everything
andy's babysitter for the rest of his
sixth birthday evening was his mom's
friend maggie who he just refers to as
aunt maggie just because she's such a
close family friend when she tells him
it's time to get ready for bed chucky
whispers in his ear that he wants to
stay up and watch the nine o'clock news
perhaps an older child would have
realized that something was wrong here
that the doll shouldn't have the
capability to communicate with him with
the context of the time of day and what
was on tv however as a kid you're still
learning about the world and you tend to
believe what you see at that age and
perceive it as normal andy gets in
trouble when he's brushing his teeth and
chuckie walks into the living room and
turns on the tv anyways i don't do that
oh no what did chucky do walk into the
living room and turn it on all by
himself maggie lays him down to sleep
and when he awoke his life would be
changed forever he's woken up by a man
named mike norris a homicide detective
with the chicago police department who
informs him that maggie had an accident
and starts asking him questions his mom
returns home from work very worried and
she orders andy to stay in his room he
realizes that the tiny footprints on the
counter near the scene of the accident
match chucky's footprints but the adults
obviously don't believe it and this
opens him up to be psychologically
manipulated by chucky his mom thinks
that he's being a troublemaker and
telling stories and again there's no
father figure in his life there's a
natural tendency for a child to attach
themselves to an adult it's basically
their survival instinct since they can't
take care of themselves karen barkley is
a struggling single mom she's exhausted
she can barely afford to get care for
her son and she has to spend a lot of
time at work psychology studies show
that lack of a father figure can lead to
low self-esteem and misbehavior and
chucky essentially tries to manipulate
the situation by inserting himself into
the father role and forcing andy to
attach himself to him chucky tells him
his real name is charles lee ray and
that he'd been sent down from heaven by
his daddy to play with them he does this
to try to gain control over andy the way
a father has control over his child and
he doesn't have the life experience to
know how this looks from someone else's
perspective and eventually just
apologizes and promises to stop making
up stories to appease his mother the
next day he brings chucky to school but
chucky tells him to sneak out before
class and take the l train to 23rd
street already demonstrating his
psychological control over him he's
guided to a rundown house where charles
old accomplice eddie caputo is staying
andy puts down the chucky doll and
wanders off to go piss but can't find
chucky when he gets back he hears
gunshots from inside the house and
probably not knowing what the sound was
he wanders up to it but lucky for him he
doesn't get too close before the place
explodes
the explosion draws in a police presence
and they find him pick him up and call
his mom once again his mom is relieved
to see that he's okay and she tries to
explain to him that nobody believes him
about chucky and if he doesn't start
telling the truth they're gonna have to
take him away from her which is honestly
kind of crazy in my opinion i mean kids
are kind of dumb i mean we all saw him
try to make breakfast he's not insane
for being a six-year-old who thinks his
talking doll is alive is he don't a lot
of kids have imaginary friends at that
age i feel like they're overreacting
here andy tries to get chucky to say
something in front of them to prove that
he's sentient but he just gives a
generic line so andy gets frustrated
[Applause]
he's asked by the county general dr
ardmore to spend a couple of days with
him for a psychological evaluation andy
is already not going to be considered
that reliable because he's a small child
but the reactions that chucky is drawing
out of him even further de-legitimize
him which is exactly the plan the next
day he's locked in a room at the
institution and sees the doll coming for
him from out his window and he's giant
now because they use the human actor for
the shot instead of a puppet of course
the doctor doesn't believe him and has
other things to attend to so andy breaks
down crying and it's here that we see
the first step of the boy's maturation
crying is often a tactic used by young
kids to get their way which is how the
doctor sees it but in this case he's got
a legitimate reason because he genuinely
believes his life is about to be cut
short at six years and one day
fortunately for him he's kind of a
creative kid and comes up with a better
plan
just as andy barkley needs a solid plan
to keep himself safe from chucky i think
everyone should have a plan to keep
themselves safe when browsing the web
that's why this video is being sponsored
by surfsharkvpn i know i should have
done this for the jaws video but the
timing just didn't work out ever use
public wi-fi at a restaurant coffee shop
hotel or airport without a vpn your
personal data including passwords photos
and credit card info can be compromised
but with surfshark your personal stuff
is shielded that includes your location
and you can actually use the vpn to
spoof your location so that websites
think you're in another country for
example by changing my location and
using netflix i can watch six more
chucky movies than i can in my home
country with a single surf shark
subscription you can connect on
unlimited devices i've literally never
seen anyone offer that before so that's
great but what's even better is the
offer that they're giving cz's world of
yours by using the link in the
description or entering code cz they
will give you 83 percent off
83 so that's basically almost free at
that point you also get three extra
months for free and there's a 30 day
money back guarantee so if you don't
like it you still have plenty of time to
cancel without getting charged for it at
all again just click that link in the
description or enter code cz for that
ridiculous price slash to get started on
surfshark bpm
knowing he doesn't have much time before
the possessed doll chucky gets to him
and he sets up a decoy in his bed and
hides under the table to wait for chucky
to enter his room it's a pretty clever
plan and it shows how his survival
instincts forced him to grow up faster
than a normal kid something he would pay
for with ptsd later on when chuckie
investigates andy locks him inside and
runs to the surgery room chuck is able
to escape out the window and he attacks
andy from above so he arms himself with
a scalpel but dr ardmore comes in and
wrestles it from his hand he's gonna
sedate him with some kind of shot when
chucky grabs the scalpel and instantly
ends dr ardmore's chances of becoming a
basketball star by slicing his achilles
tent then instantly ends dr ardmore's
chance of becoming
anything other than the late dr ardmore
by giving him a taste of his own
shockband thing which i don't know what
that thing is exactly andy remembers his
mom's instructions to go home if he's
ever in trouble even though he's a
little i gotta give him credit for being
able to find his way back to the
apartment in downtown chicago when i was
six i actually lived less than two miles
from his building but the center he
escapes from is not close to that at
least not in real life he probably had
to take the train again but this time
without chucky to guide him through it i
guess the kid's got some street smarts
after all he hears chucky approach and
emerges with the baseball bat but chucky
makes like a kyle hendricks change up
and evades the bats and that's actually
a bad analogy because hendrix likes the
pitch to contact but as i'm recording
this in 2021 we don't really have swing
and miss guys i mean maybe justin steele
but it's a little bit too early to tell
so i'm working with what i got here so
anyways chucky chases him around the
apartment with a knife then eventually
knocks him out with the bats
when andy awakes he finds that he's been
saved by his mom and detective norris
but they aren't out of the woods just
yet because chucky just won't die his
mom traps the doll in the fireplace and
we see how andy has matured past his
dependency on chucky as a father figure
or as a companion
candy no please we're friends to the end
remember this is the end friend
[Music]
however he wouldn't totally get over
that friendship right away despite being
burnt to a crisp chucky still causes
more mayhem until norris is finally able
to end it by shooting the doll through
the heart but a lot of damage is done
because andy witnessed all of this
horrendous stuff up close and personal
the whole ordeal represents an
environment of domestic turmoil which
the national library of medicine cites
can result in developmental trauma
disorder a child's brain still spends a
lot of time developing after birth and
it may react to these events causing
abnormal behavior some symptoms include
hyper-vigilance and inexplicable fear
deep-seated shame and isolation from
making connections dr arthur becker
weedman does a good job of explaining
this in an interview at nyu's child
study center
their stress response system is always
activated
and the stress response system is
focused on survival we see this in the
final shot of the original child's play
as andy stares at the severed head
perhaps unable to believe that chucky is
really dead he's not going to let his
guard down today or during the years
that would follow and he had to testify
in court his mom backed up his story but
the police for whatever reason did not
causing mrs barkley to look crazy and be
sent to the looney bed the judge ordered
psychiatric care for andy landing him in
the midtown children's crisis center
he's haunted by bad dreams of chucky but
he doesn't want to talk about it with a
psychiatrist an example of his emotional
isolation caused by dtd instead of
telling about his bad dreams to the
shrink he tells what actually happened
in 1988 it is october 1990 when andy is
designated for foster care assuming this
calendar is accurate to real weekdays
the center tells the foster parents phil
and joanne simpson that the stories
about the doll were some kind of coping
mechanism for what really happened well
in order to come to terms with something
he couldn't possibly understand he
turned it all into a kind of fairy tale
he insisted his doll was responsible
said it was possessed by the soul of
charles lee ray on the way home they're
newly flattened by a good guy's truck
the dolls and merchandise are still
popular and this makes it much harder
for andy to recover because he's
constantly being triggered into high
alert after meeting his new foster
sister kyle his ptsd is activated once
again when an old good guy doll falls
out of the closet that night joanne
reads him a bedtime story hoping to give
him a sense of normalcy andy really
misses his mom and doesn't want to be
left alone because even now nearly two
years after his two days with chucky
he's paranoid he asked mrs simpson to
sing him to sleep like his mother used
to but as he dozes off he's still
alarmed by sounds in the nights the next
morning he and kyle are both grounded
when this broken statue is discovered so
andy helps kyle with the laundry and
takes a puff of her cigarette while
holding it for her she tries to explain
that cigarettes are bad for him and that
only grown-ups are allowed to do things
that are bad for them which he counters
by saying that she's not a grown-up
which gets on her nerves i find the
dynamic interesting because smoking is
often used as an unhealthy coping
mechanism by adults and andy is getting
involved with it at way too young of an
age but he's seen more agony than a lot
of adults have this may also have been a
gateway for him because he seemed to be
a smoker later on in life it seems that
andy is also self-conscious about the
burden that his psychological issues
present he overhears mr and mrs simpson
debating whether they're qualified to
take care of him which plays into the
shame and low self-esteem issues
connected to his psychological issues
he's also still paranoid he sees the
good guy doll that mrs simpson was
supposed to have gotten rid of
downstairs and he's off put by this
small hesitation
hi i'm
tommy and he decides to check the
batteries to make sure this wasn't a
repeat situation that evening he hangs
out with kyle in the backyard i imagine
it was good for him to have a real
friend it goes back to the attachment
theory that i brought up earlier he's
not as comfortable with his foster
parents because he senses that they feel
that they can't handle him but kyle's in
the same situation that he's in and they
kind of bond over that so next night
chucky makes his move against andy by
tying him up and gagging him with a sock
in order to perform the voodoo ritual
and transfer his conscience out of the
doll's body and into his we've already
established that the kid's been dealing
with some nightmare issues it's not
really something that's explored again
going forward but this is the third time
now that he's woken up to some horrific
circumstance caused by chucky i imagine
that makes it pretty hard to fall asleep
this time he gets out of it because kyle
had snuck out that night and she was
coming back in through his window
forcing chucky to go inanimate so that
nobody finds out that he's really alive
this once again put andy in a bad
position he doesn't have an explanation
for how he got tied up so he's forced to
tell the truth which makes him look like
a nut andy is still too young to
understand that the word of a
seven-year-old will never convince them
he needs proof mr simpson is fed up with
all of andy's chucky stories and he
locks the doll in the basement the next
day would be andy's first at his new
school where he would be pushed to his
breaking point and go on the offensive
for the first time
[Music]
in the morning kyle walks andy to the
school bus and tries to give him some
advice for his first day telling him not
to act nervous because andy's constantly
looking back for chucky it's not just
chucky that he has to worry about though
there's also this incredibly hostile kid
on the bus
i know i bring this up every time and
you're probably sick of seeing it now if
you watch my channel but i just can't
get over this kid what happened to him
why is he like this for later
but it's here that we see the isolation
aspect of andy's trauma fully on display
he sits alone on the bus and plays alone
in the playground it looks like he's
actually just pretending to play so he
can keep an eye out for chucky at the
end of the day andy finds a good guy
doll hidden in the cabinet and gets
chewed out by the teacher for writing
obscenities on his schoolwork which he
obviously didn't do and ends up in
detention the teacher locks the doll in
a closet and when andy gets up to
investigate and see if this was in fact
chucky he sees this
he finds himself locked in the classroom
and has to use the window to escape but
after explaining everything to his
foster parents they remember the broken
statue and viewed this as another
example of andy acting out which they
had been warned about by the center they
fostered them from mr simpson takes him
to the basement and shows him that the
doll is still lying there where he left
it but andy knows what he saw at school
that day in the middle of the night he
wakes up and steals the carving knife
from the kitchen and bravely goes down
to confronts chucky but the good guy is
no longer in his spots chucky surprises
him from above but he's able to recover
in time to slice chucky in the head
causing the doll to retreat however this
noise wakes up mr simpson and chucky
silently grabs a fire poker to trip him
on the stairs he's left hanging upside
down and when chucky releases him the
impact breaks his neck tallying up
another victim for charles lee ray mrs
simpson was always the more patient of
the two foster parents often standing up
for andy against phil's concerns about
his psyche but the loss of her husband
from something that she perceives to be
andy's fault ends up being her last
straw before being shipped back to the
children's crisis center andy tries to
warn kyle that chucky is still down in
the cellar don't let him get you too the
woman at the crisis center grace puts
andy to bed but as soon as she leaves
the room he's back up getting changed
out of his pajamas and into some warmer
clothes and running shoes compared to
chucky's first incarnation in 88 andy's
already being more proactive and not
just letting himself be the victim of
what happens to him anymore by the time
chucky arrives andy is basically already
waiting for him we can see how he's
matured in this way he's given up on
trying to convince the adults to help
him and he's just gonna do whatever he
can to protect himself on his own he
probably picked this up from kyle
every time it happens
it just makes me stronger
because it reminds me that the only one
i can count on is myself the fire alarm
goes off in the middle of the night and
andy spots chuckie at the bottom of the
stairs in kyle's arms grace thinks that
kyle one of her former troublemakers was
the one to pull the alarm and pulls them
both into her office where she's stabbed
in the heart by chucky snap out of it
act like you've never seen a dead body
before i mean
he
he has a point i mean andy should be
used to this by now with andy at
knifepoint they sneak away from the
center and get into the back of a
newspaper truck where chucky tries to
perform the soul transfer ritual again
but is again interrupted by kyle who
cuts off the truck driver forcing andy
and chucky to flee on foot kyle chases
them back to the play pals factory where
the good guy dolls are manufactured
where chucky frantically finds a spot to
perform his ritual but this time
discovers that he's too late from his
incarnation chucky only has a limited
amount of time to transfer his soul out
of his body before turning human and
being stuck in the good guy doll until
death with possession out of the picture
his consolation plan is revenge you know
if you can't join him kill him luckily
for andy kyle knocks over a wall of good
guy boxes and takes his hands to help
him flee a long chase through the
factory's assembly line culminates when
andy opens the scalding hot plastic
overflow valve and rushes to save kyle
from the heat press it's interesting to
see how he's always the one to attack
chucky with heats and this wouldn't be
the last time either eventually it's
kyle who grabs a loose air hose and
forces it into chucky's mouth the hot
plastic dries around the hose causing
chucky's head to blow up like a balloon
and explode like eddie caputo's house
the sun rises as they walk out of the
factory where are we going
home
where's home
andy
i have no idea and neither do i because
we don't see andy for another nine years
according to this file andy is now 16
years old if andy turned six in november
1988 he would turn 16 in november of
1998. it looks like there's snow on the
ground but it's melting so i'm gonna go
with spring 1999 as the next time we see
it andy is put into kent military school
for delinquent activities prompting
probation and juvenile authority's
jurisdiction we've never really seen
andy to be a bad kid but since most
rational people were of the belief that
chucky was never alive it's easy to
blame andy for a lot of those things
that happened however it's likely that
he did get into some actual trouble in
his pre-teen and early teen years and
it's not hard to imagine that with no
parental guidance he could have found
himself on the wrong side of the law a
few times since chucky never comes back
between 1991 and 1999 it looks like andy
did kind of turn into a delinquent on
his own so we have to assume that he was
not a well-disciplined kid and he finds
himself in military school because of it
when the colonel reads his file he tells
him that he'll have to behave no more
fantasies of killer dolls while getting
his haircut andy discovers that the good
guy doll is back on the market after
being pulled in the aftermath of bad
publicity and lawsuits from what
transpired at the factory that evening
he discovers his new roommate harold
whitehurst has been locked in the closet
by cadet lieutenant sheldon it's hard to
say for sure what was going through
andy's head here but it looks as if he's
still getting flashbacks of chucky
because the way he approaches the closet
is very similar to when chucky was
locked in the closet at andy's school
during drill formations sheldon picks on
andy because he's new but one other
cadet stands up for him which leads andy
to finding a new flame
andy takes a liking to a female cadet
named kristin da silva there are
obviously a lot of theories about dating
compatibility but it looks like what
they're going for here is the opposites
attract theory de silva is fearless
standing up to her superior officer
outperforming her class at the shooting
range and sneaking around the halls at
night andy is traumatized by a
children's toy can't hit a target and is
basically a runner he doesn't seem to
stay in one place too long the idea
behind this theory is that we as humans
look for a partner who fills in the
traits that we lack so da silva is a
natural fit for him during marching
drills one day andy is distracted when
he sees colonel cochran no not connell
cochran cochran and carrying around a
good guy doll outside he doesn't have
any proof that it's chucky yet but it is
a strange sight to see at a military
academy and it causes him to drop his
rifle on the ground which gets him in
big trouble with shelton the trainees
are drawn away not long after when they
hear the screams of a garbage man and
run to go help him only to find his
lifeless arm sticking out that night
whitehurst informs barkley that he's
gotta unpack or shelton will be on him
again we saw the same thing back at the
foster home where kyle had yet to unpack
her things after three weeks of living
there this tells me that andy has also
probably bounced around to a lot of
different homes over the years and
doesn't like getting comfortable
anywhere because he's moved around so
much whitehurst also asks him if he ever
got a package and he's confused at who
he'd be sending him one and he puts up a
picture of him and his mom from when he
was six these two things tell me that
she's probably still institutionalized
her life really got messed up by this
whole ordeal more than anyone andy feels
a sharp pain in his ankle and discovers
chucky hiding under his bed with a knife
he finds out that this time chucky's
just out for revenge previously andy's
life was protected because chuckie
needed him alive to transfer his soul
into him but this time chucky revealed
his true nature to a younger cadet named
ronald tyler before getting to andy as a
result chucky can only transfer himself
into tyler now however now being bigger
and older andy's able to get the upper
hand and start pounding chucky into the
ground but that's when shelton hears the
disturbance comes in and confiscates the
doll and tells andy you tell whitehears
he's off the hook huh
i got myself another slave once again
andy's not gonna wait for chucky to get
to him so he sneaks out with a knife
while shelton is asleep but chucky's
appearance causes him to flinch and wake
shelton up anyway we do see how andy has
matured and gotten a bit smarter about
what he lets out of his mouth because
when sheldon asks him what he's doing he
keeps it vague you wouldn't believe me
however this gives time for chucky to
scurry away causing it to look like the
good guy doll had been stolen and
shelton forces the entire dorm to march
outside hoping to make an example of the
thief andy is concerned that chucky is
going to get to tyler and possess his
body so he tries to bail out of the
punishment but shelton catches him and
punches him in the gut
[Applause]
he's forced back into the marching
circle where his roommate whitehurst
asks him what he's trying to prove by
constantly pissing off shelton and after
some prodding andy tells him the truth
about the doll being alive and coming
after tyler like everybody else in
andy's life whitehurst doesn't believe
it that night the kent academy students
learn of the passing of colonel cochrane
and andy can already assume that chucky
was involved in some way the next
morning andy is relieved to see that
tyler is okay and gets up during
breakfast to warn him about chuckie but
someone trips him on his way and the
whole dining hall laughs at him just
highlighting how even here barkley is an
outcast when he tries to convince tyler
that chucky is bad he doesn't believe
him so andy gives him a pocketknife to
hopefully protect himself with his
suspicions are heightened again when he
notices whitehurst looking like he's
seen a ghost or in his case a children's
doll possessed by a serial killer this
day would mark the beginning of kent
military academy's annual war games
where the student body would be split
into two teams for a giant game of
capture the flag involving paintball
guns and camping in the woods to protect
your team's flag that evening after
andy's team has set up camp they tell
scary stories by the campfire and andy
takes off on his own to try to stop
chucky before he can get to thailand
which is pretty selfless because andy's
probably going to be safest staying
right where he is surrounded by an army
of young soldiers and training desilva
notices him break off from the group and
goes after him and she shows him an
overlook where the two can see a
carnival off in the distance andy's
response as they share this moment
together really shows how strange his
life has become
i almost forgot there are places like
that
people just go to have fun
listen
somebody's out there it's a perfect
example of why barkley and dasilva work
together they're literally hiding in the
middle of nowhere and he's concerned
about chucky and she doesn't have a fear
in the world she kisses him not the
other way around all right that's our
boy our little serial spilling brat is
finally growing up that same evening he
steals a map from cadet lieutenant
sheldon's tent and uses it to figure out
where the red team might be hiding out
so he can try to save tyler whitehurst
notices him leaving so andy asks him to
go with but he won't budge so as always
barkley's on his own when he gets to the
red cap another kid tells him that tyler
won awol or absent without leave with
some guy named charles eventually he
does find tyler and the rest of andy's
unit catches up with him as they receive
a strange message over the radios in
which chucky tells barkley that he must
bring the kid up to the old jeep or
there will be hell to pay andy realizes
his catch 22 when he hears da silva's
voice in the background of chucky's
transmission as a group they all go to
the jeep and shelton instructs tyler and
barkley to go ahead and draw them out
while the rest of the troops circle
around the area they go ahead towards
chucky and kristen and the rest of the
blue team steps out of the trees and
opens fire but hits nothing seriously
not a single one of them hits their
target i mean what are they teaching at
this school anyway i guess it doesn't
make a huge difference in the end though
because they're only shooting paintball
guns and chucky has been known to endure
a few real bullets in the past the red
team however is not using paintball guns
chucky switched out their ammo before
the games began so they're using real
live ammunition but since this is the
first confrontation between the two
teams they don't know it yet so when
they show up on the scene and open fire
on their opponents lieutenant shelton is
shot and killed was andy's first thought
that he's not really gonna miss
lieutenant shelton
no comments sheldon's second in command
and presumed best friend major ellis
goes into a rage and tackles andy
assuming he was somehow responsible
given his prior clashes with shelton and
general connection to any mischief going
on since his arrival all of this
distraction allows chucky to deliver yet
another blow to andy barkley's already
reeling team of fighters
[Music]
when andy sees tyler running after
chucky he follows them and mr silva
follows him for backup they end up at
the carnival and go to the security tent
to see if maybe someone had spotted
tyler but upon their arrival they
discover the security guard has already
been taken out being the better shots da
silva takes the gun out of the guards
holster andy spots chucky threatening
tyler as the two head into the employee
entrance of the devil's lair dark ride
which i mentioned this in my child's
play 3 episode of things you missed but
this carnival ride is so cool it's
better than a lot of actual permanent
dark rides i mean it's certainly got
superstar limo and garfield's nightmare
beats and probably a lot of others da
silva opens fire against chucky and he
shoots back wounding her in the lag and
he ties up her injury and she hands the
gun off to him to continue on after
chucky this is a significant moment for
his character when andy arrived he was
the helpless one being protected by the
silva now he has to use what she taught
him at the shooting range to protect her
and tyler when chuckie begins the ritual
andy remembers everything that she
taught him and he's able to land a
couple shots first shooting off the
doll's right arm then landing one in the
chest when he goes to save tyler chucky
jumps on him and tyler unintentionally
pays back the favor that andy had done
him by trying to tell him the truth
about chucky earlier by handing back the
knife that andy had originally given him
using that barkley is able to cut off
chucky's other hand and throw him into
the giant spinning fan blade where he
dies for the third time but notably this
is the first time he's vanquished by
andy himself and this third incarnation
has sparked the most growth from andy as
a character he gets tyler back to safety
and sees his girl da silva off as she's
carted out in an ambulance right after
this he's arrested though it's unclear
if this was for the trespassing or
shooting weapon in public or if he's
being blamed for what happened to
shelton and whitehurst at this point it
looks like he's right back in the same
scenario he's been in two times before
and he'll probably be kicked out and
find himself on the road to a new home
once again however this time is a little
bit different and andy has himself to
thank for it because instead of just
crying chucky like he had in the past
and expecting people to believe him he
focuses on trying to take chucky down
himself and this results in many other
students discovering chucky's true
nature on their own i'm guessing because
so many people saw him with their own
eyes they were able to back up his story
get him out of jail and even prevent him
from being expelled from the military
academy barkley would graduate from kent
academy which is not just an academic
and physical accomplishment but it also
represents a personal achievement for
him by being able to find somewhere to
call home for the rest of high school
i'm guessing this is also around the
time when andy's mom karen barkley is
released from the mental institution
that she'd been locked in for over a
decade it's not known what became of his
relationship with kristin da silva
because we don't see andy again for
another 14 and a half years during that
time he's grown up and moved into an
apartment he seems to be a fairly
well-adjusted guy but that's not to say
he isn't still hiding some demons now
this is where the timeline gets a little
bit iffy but i'm gonna use the dates
that were given in the movies and try to
make it make sense so there are a couple
of events that happen off camera the
first is when andy learns about nika
pierce in the news she's a disabled
woman from rhode island who claims that
chucky came and took out her entire
family saved for her and her knees of
course she gets the old karen barkley
treatment and is sentenced to a mental
hospital then at some point andy is
attacked by another chucky incarnation
possibly the same one that attacked nika
and he defeats him and decapitates the
doll's head he nails it to a board and
locks him inside of a save i'm guessing
his intention was to keep him alive in
there so he could no longer be
reincarnated i know this is confusing
because these events are out of order
from how we see them in the movies but
bear with me here so the next time andy
appears is on november 1st 2013 as seen
in this timestamp recording where andy
takes the decapitated chucky head to
nica's doctor to try to prove that she
isn't crazy this is eight days before
andy's 31st birthday his attempt to free
nika doesn't work because the doctor
assumes that it's some kind of trick or
animatronic then we see andy again on
november 8th one day before his 31st
birthday we know this because he
mentions it to his mom on the phone
yeah i'm definitely coming for my
birthday tomorrow
[Music]
no don't give me anything yeah i think
andy loves his mom but he's totally cool
with her never getting him another
birthday present again as you can
probably see from that clip andy has
just received another package and chucky
is busy sawing his way out of it my
thought is that this chucky is not the
same one that andy has locked in the
save the dates just don't work out wait
a minute there's two of them it totally
could be a mistake made by the
filmmakers but both events are given a
date in the same movie the cult of
chucky it also shows the date of nica's
trial april 7th in cursivechucky there
are a couple of things that happen after
the trial and then there's the six month
gap before andy receives the package
which basically puts us in early
november which is why i threw out that
one document at the very beginning of
this video if you remember that so andy
receives chucky in the mail again on
november 8th and this time he's prepared
and blows his head off
play with this
at some point he checks on the safe so
he now knows that chucky has figured out
how to inhabit more than one body at a
time this answer is a possible question
later on chucky doesn't expect andy to
know that he can take on multiple bodies
but andy does know
you thought i was the only one wait
what are you doing
what's going on
[Music]
chucky didn't expect one of the other
chuckies to be kept alive in andy's safe
so when he sends himself in the mail he
accidentally reveals the fact that
chucky can duplicate himself if you're
confused just think of it like this
chucky gained the ability to inhabit
more than one doll at once so he sent
one to attack andy which andy kept and
then he sent another to attack andy
before his birthday which he most likely
killed so i'm going to give you about 10
to 16 seconds to process that and then
we can jump back in and analyze the rest
of andy's story
at some point over the next few years
andy moved to this log cabin he uses it
to house a very extensive collection of
firearms and it seems that he's become
quite the hunter i guess old shelton and
ellis at the military academy had an
impact on him after all unfortunately
for him while he's on a date with his
redhead you'd think he'd steer clear of
redheads she's put off by his
familiarity with guns he tries to
explain that he's not like a gun fanatic
i mean i don't know about that but
rather that he just wants to be able to
protect himself when she asks what he
needs to protect himself from he
realizes that she's googled him she
knows who he is he explains that he just
didn't want to scare her off with his
tragic backstory but she ends up getting
scared off anyways and dumps him i mean
if she didn't want to get involved with
him then that's her choice but did she
really have to wait until they were all
ready on this fancy date to tell him
that seems like something that could
have been accomplished with a phone call
andy sees his past history with chucky
as the scapegoat for his romantic
frustration so that night he opens up
the safe and vents those frustrations
into chucky by torturing him andy keeps
a vigilant eye on the news to try to
find out where chucky is going to pop up
next and in january of 2017 he has his
answer in the form of this perez hilton
article if you don't remember perez
hilton he's like an early internet
gossip guy he was a blogger before he
got on youtube in 2007 and i guess his
blog is actually still going to this day
i wouldn't have thought it to be around
in 2017 though so the fact that andy's
getting his chucky news from basically
the forgotten tabloid of the internet
means that chucky is very much still an
urban legend in the eyes of major media
corps the article suggests that chucky
is at it again and two patients at the
asylum are now dead barkley doesn't want
anyone to suffer the same fate that he
had so he decides to try to intervene
once more he gets another good guy doll
this one not tainted by voodoo or
charles lee ray in any way and plants a
gun inside of it he also gives this one
a haircut so he can easily tell that
it's his and mails it to nika at the
asylum by doing this he's basically
giving himself a plan b since he won't
be allowed to bring a weapon into the
mental hospital this is his way of
sneaking one in if there's anything we
can say about andy it's that he's had no
shortage of creative plans to make the
most of his situation while andy is
driving there he receives a call from
chuckie's wife tiffany valentine yeah
chucky does have a wife and somehow this
is the first time that it's come up in
this video she leaves him with a one
word message that he's supposed to know
the meaning of and the message is
disembowel this may be a setup for
something that hasn't happened yet and
if that is the case it's kind of ironic
because andy is about to disembowel a
chucky doll to get his gun back when
andy arrives at the asylum he asks the
security guard to speak with nika or her
doctor but the guy informs him that
visiting hours are over because of the
urgency of the situation he commits
himself to the institution by attacking
the guard and he finds himself locked in
solitary confinement it seems like this
measure might be a little bit extreme on
his part but remember he's no stranger
to this kind of care that is being
locked up alone in a psychiatric
facility he even sits in the same pose
that he did 28 years ago after waiting
for some time his plan starts to come to
fruition when the short-haired chucky
doll now brought to life with the soul
of charles lee ray breaks into andy's
room and throws a scalpel into his leg
however this is unlike any chucky
encounter that he's had before because
andy knows exactly what he's doing he
pins chucky to the wall and disembowels
him to retrieve the gun this is the end
he uses it to shoot him several times
before stomping his head into the ground
until it's mush unfortunately for andy
this is where things stop going
according to plan because he soon
discovers that naked pierce has already
been possessed by chucky's soul his
entire journey was essentially for
nothing because this time he was the one
who was too late she locks him in the
room and heads off to cause more mayhem
the boy who suffered so much
psychological turmoil after basically
overcoming a bad case of developmental
trauma disorder finds himself locked
away in a nut house anyway and andy is
trapped away in that room forever at
least as far as we know because that
covers the entire history so far of andy
barkley i'm guessing we will see this
character again before long so when that
time comes there may be an update video
or maybe i'll wait a little bit until we
see more of his story whatever the case
may be there will be more chucky content
here on this channel very soon so if you
can't get enough of the chuck remember
to subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring the death bell
for all notifications and i will see you
in the next one assuming we both
survived
[Music]